i love talking to this guy he loves
football as much as anybody else that
i've ever met who loves football
and he takes his job of guarding the
flame
that is the greatness of the pro
football hall of fame and all the men
who played football who make that place
uh a wonderful spot to visit and all
this man does
is spend every breathing moment to try
and figure out how
you as a fan can get to canton ohio love
it and want to come back
he is the president and ceo ceo of the
pro football hall of fame uh david baker
how are you sir
hey i'm doing good rich and i am so
sorry that we didn't get to see you this
year at the gold jacket dinner come on
uh but next next year we're going to
have twice the fun in 21. now it's my
question for you is
what is the plan uh to just uh or is it
just gonna be like a a three-day affair
will there be two jacket dinners will
there be two enshrinement ceremonies
what do we have david what's the plan
well right right now rich i'll tell you
what you know we went through a lot of
different contingency plans and right
you know
considered virtual you know
enshrinements and all the things
but as you know for these guys the
ability to walk that gauntlet
oh yeah with all those other hall of
famers uh
means so much uh you know if you
remember kurt warner
stood up there and he's about to go into
the gauntlet and you could see him mouth
the words
oh my god these are all my heroes and
the journey that helped them get to
canton wasn't just themselves it was
teammates and
coaches and and family so we kind of
felt that we really need to do it in
person
so we postponed everything until next
year
we will have the same game the steelers
and the cowboys on thursday night
on friday night we're going to have a
gold jacket dinner but we're going to
need you to do it a little bit
differently
okay because we're probably going to
give out maybe like 18
to 19 gold jackets that night but it'll
be still be very very special
the next day we'll have the the parade
which should be the biggest ever
uh saturday we will have the
enshrinement of the centennial
class of 20 for 2020 and then the
following day we will have another
enshrinement
that will be the class of 21 which is
likely to have this guy peyton manning
in it i've heard about it
and maybe a couple others like charles
woodson calvin johnson
and then sun monday we will close it out
with
possibly another game but most likely
you know kind of a concert for legends
but i think it'll
be you know i think it'll be one of the
best gatherings in the history of
football
uh because we are likely to have 160
hall of famers for that gathering well
you know david i'm i'm knocking on wood
uh for something like that because you
know you want to talk about a group of
people who are
in the the group of those who might be
susceptible to the worst of covet it is
the age group of the guys that you need
to have coming back all the time and
and and that's the beautiful part about
and i'm so thrilled you made the
decision
to not go virtual because there's
nothing like
seeing this in person nothing and doing
it in person
nothing zero well yeah and again i'm
just
you know how much respect i have for you
and
you are canton's guys and we'll be as
long as you want to come do this
well even when i got this job rich
um i i kind of thought it was weird to
have this tv show
and all the commissioner and i are doing
are giving out a gold jacket
but when you are there i mean the hair
on your arms in the back your neck goes
up
and it is chilling to see all these guys
together there is a critical mass
of of character and legacies there
uh that that i don't think you can where
else is there a dinner for
4 800 people uh that have this kind of
people in it
i know and and it's just a bunch of uh
big time fans of football all in the
into the civic center in downtown canton
and there really is nothing like it it's
certainly since it's a
it's the largest gathering of ohioans
that i like to speak to and i
at the beginning of when i used to uh
emcee this
a michigan reference uh uh was easier
for me to make
you know but what do you what do you
mean at the beginning i'm talking
every year since i've been here okay
come on now wait a minute
your listeners don't understand that the
way we seat
you said on the other side of the podium
i said on the other side of the podium
and the commissioner's on my left that's
right so i have to listen to you guys
banner back and forth
uh through the whole event but but it is
special it is and
just like having chris berman at the
enshrinement which is really special
um we've told chris man as long as you
breathe
you can come do the ensign and i feel
the same way about you
thank you david that that means a lot i
got the president and ceo of pro
football hall of fame here and
um you one of the things that you're so
excellent at david
is is realizing the moments that can be
created
and that how fans can feel in those
moments because
we feel like we're there okay like
that's that's what you're talking about
about that jacket dinner that's what
you're talking about
about everything to do at the festival
that is the pro football hall of fame
and you're um you're bringing into
um ushering in the uh the class by
knocking on their doors at the super
bowl
where they're stationed in their rooms
waiting for that knock on the door in
the video
of you knocking on the door and seeing
the moment that these guys
are informed by you that they are now
football
immortal is amazing when did you come up
with that concept
walk me through that david i'll tell you
my first year here
we we did decide to bring all the 18
finalists
uh back to the super bowl which was in
new york that year
uh new york new jersey the honors show
was going to be
at the radio city music hall and we went
a little long
as we normally do on selection saturday
and i started calling people and i
called
michael strahan because he was living in
new york and on the other side of town
we had to rush him over
then i called derek brooks because derek
was a friend of mine
before i got this job and i just wanted
to tell my buddy he was in the hall of
fame
and then i called the punter ray guy
from oakland
and uh ray had been eligible for 29
years
and not gotten the call or what we would
say now is the knock
and uh he almost didn't answer because
i'm area code 714 as you know instead of
330. right and um he you know he did and
i said ray dave baker the new president
of the hall of fame
and then he said yes sir and that slow
southern mississippi
draw and i said ray
it is my great pleasure and with that i
could hear him drop the phone
i could hear him fall to the ground his
wife sandy is going honey baby are you
okay
and this goes on for like two minutes
and i think oh my god i've killed my own
first hall of fame
and he got to his feet after about two
minutes which as you know
you know it's certainly under air
michael irvin's
you know filled more than two minutes
just doing his pick last week for you
but you know two minutes was a long time
and he got up and then he said
uh hey mr president i'm sorry he says
i just want you to know i don't think i
understood until now
how much this meant to me and you know
my thought was man we got to let fans
see that yep
and since then we've kind of been on
this journey of
you know you know again i love knocking
on the door of kurt warner because
having been commissioner of the arena
football league have meant a lot to me
um but i've every one of them cries
uh you know jerry cramer who waited 45
years
for goodness sakes and and when that
happens
what is absolutely incredible rich is
you know and you've seen this i think in
some of your interviews but for this
special moment um you know jerry jones
had his family inside he's got eight
billion dollars
and this was something money couldn't
buy they're going nuts
but at that moment when you tell them
they're all crying
uh they're not thinking about how much
money they made they're not thinking
about their records or their
rings or their lombardi's uh i guarantee
you
um you know we we we walked on the uh
set there at cbs for bill cower in the
next day oh that was amazing
johnson yes and i guarantee you that
jimmy johnson was thinking about his
mother
i absolutely know it um i i i
you know they think about their their
dad that wouldn't let him quit or their
coach
that encouraged him to do more uh a
teammate that sacrificed to get him
into the hall and it's a special moment
uh it's uh
there are so many moments like that when
you knock on the door when you give them
the jacket when they unveil their bust
when we present them their hall of fame
ring of excellence in the fall in front
of their stadium
um you know john stallworth had the
great line when you put that gold jacket
on me
it was like all the history of the
league surrounded me from the day they
first laced up a pigskin
to the presentation of that last
lombardi and it's
it i think it actually has a significant
impact on them and
and you know a lot of our hall of famers
are your friends uh
you know like terrell or michael and and
and i've seen guys
you know frankly like randy moss i think
it it changes
every one of their lives instead of
being
somebody who played the game they are
now you know
the um the absolute ambassador the best
there's ever been in this game
you know there have been about 330
million that have played the game 5
million in college
tomorrow night or tonight sorry we will
unveil
25 488 names in centennial plaza
of those who played the game
professionally in the first year of the
nfl
but there's only 326 right now in the
hall of fame there's only 176
living gold jackets so this is really
elite company and and what i love about
what we do rich here
i really don't think it's about the
worship of football heroes
and i don't even think it's about the
worship of the game of football but
every one of these guys you know and you
know them well they did not fall out of
bed great
they fought to be great they persevered
to be great
and they're not perfect people you know
for them being great was
not coming out of your nose and blood
coming out of your mouth and
and fighting for every yard to be great
but i think we can learn from that how
to be a better father
or or a better mother or a better
company or community
and maybe right now a better country uh
so i
we call it the church of football here
in canton ohio uh and it's a it's a
wonderful place to be
david baker pro football hall of fame
president and ceo
we are having this conversation i know
the nfl 100 season was last year but
today is
in fact the day that 100 years ago the
nfl was born this is the 100th birthday
of the nfl today as you and i
are talking um the 21st century however
uh has hit uh canton already walk me
through
on the couple minutes we have left here
about the improvements you mentioned
about
uh the centennial uh ceremony that
you're having tonight i know that you've
got the draft
uh coming to cleveland in 2021 as well
walk me through what you got
david well i'll tell you tonight what
we're going to do
the good people of canton ohio the nfl
does a lot for a lot of cities but i
can't think of any city that does more
for the nfl than canton ohio
and you know they raised 12 and a half
million dollars themselves
to memorialize the first century of the
nfl which started right here in canton
on september 17th of 1920 exactly 100
years ago from today
with 10 teams that came together they
elected a native american and maybe one
of the best athletes to ever
walk the face of the earth jim thorpe to
be their president
and you know that became the nfl
to what it's going to be today so in
this
award-winning park that will unveil
tonight at halftime of the
bengals browns game you know there are
monuments to every city
to every host and nfl team uh to dayton
and racine and
providence but like i also said there
are
there are pillars for every decade
that have the name of 25 488 players
every single player if you played it
down in the national football league
your name
is going to be on one of these pillars
and frankly we put them in
two nights ago rich it was a fun thing
for me to go see my own son's name
sam baker who played eight years with
the valkyries and when i saw it
i thought about him as a young kid
and then in high school and then playing
with pete carroll at usc and
draft day and then playing with the
falcons and it occurred to me that every
one of those 25
488 names um every single one of them
has a story just like sam's and and so
we're going to keep their
legacy forever we are going to
have some great events at centennial
plaza when the draft is in cleveland and
we're going to partner with cleveland on
that
and then we'll come back to have what i
think will be
by far the greatest ensignment ever i
think the greatest gathering in football
uh the first weekend in august a labor
day of next year by the way we have the
black
college football hall of fame classic
because we're
now the home of the black college
football hall of fame
for all those players that were the
greatest players to come out out of
historical black
uh colleges and i know your colleague
steve weiss
there is a big fan of that so now it's
going to be a great year and
we've got a lot of other things coming
up and if i could just say one
thing real quick no time short here but
uh
i got to tell you how proud i am of all
of you associated with the nfl
uh the commissioner gets raked over the
coals the union gets raked over the
goals the officials get raped over the
goals
but i'll tell you last week was the
greatest tribute
all of you could have paid to those guys
who started this league 100 years ago
and whose shoulders upon you stand
because i'll tell you
it showed exactly what you can do if a
whole lot of
people put their personal interest aside
and decide we're going to make something
happen and it was a great first week
it was great football it was pretty
great officiating
our broadcast teams get great and i
think it's a real message
to the rest of america that hey if we
huddle up and do the same thing
there's a lot of good ahead for our
country david you are the man
you keep doing what you're doing uh i
missed hanging with you
um but that means we just get twice the
fun next year and i
can't wait for it we'll chat soon thank
you rich god bless man right here
right right back at you david baker pro
football hall of fame president and c
you know
ceo and i look forward to seeing that at
halftime tonight on nfl network